[Musique]
je veux donner la réponse tout de suite
en fait vous n'êtes pas du tout ce que
vous croyez vous êtes beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus vaste que cela d'une façon
générale nous avons tendance à penser
que nous sommes moi moi fait d'un cor un
organisme
or mentale pensées et émotions
sensations perception de penser mon
histoire personnelle ma mémoire
mon vécu mes capacités tout ce que je
sais moi moi aussi pilote de cet
organisme
j'ai l'idée que c'est moi qui pensent
que c'est moi qui effectuent des choix
que c'est moi qui pose des actes eh bien
non en réalité nous sommes beaucoup plus
basse que cela tout autre il n'y a pas
de pilote dans la machine mais j'ai
d'abord vous parlez un peu mon histoire
personnelle à moi qui n'en est pas
trente cinq ans de recherche de maladies
graves
plusieurs expériences mystiques des
dizaines de rencontres et une définitive
celle alex kochis je croyais être moi et
finalement je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais pas moi j'étais ce que je suis
la première maladie grave et est vrai
tout était nécessaire les deux étaient
nécessaires la première avait une
composante psychosomatique
et elle m'a forcé à m'intéresser à l'abc
quai à mes pensées à la façon dont je
voyais le monde à mes croyances
je pensais savoir beaucoup de choses à
propos pleins de choses quand j'ai 20
ans je me trompais et il a bien fallu je
m'en rende compte
mais cette maladie a servi à ça et par
exemple je moi je pensais que les psys
était aussi fou que leurs malades
il ya longtemps et grâce à cette maladie
bien j'ai fini mes études dans la silice
de psychiatrie je suis devenu petit moi
même et au bout de quelques années en
fait il est quelque chose qui était
ennuyeux c'est que écouter les problèmes
des autres toute la journée
eh bien on avait assez et puis d'un
autre côté il ya un mouvement intérieur
qui me poussait à continuer je
comprenais pas qu'est ce qui se passe là
il y avait une question qui me trottait
dans la tête
est ce que par hasard il y aurait
quelque chose après la mort parce que
s'il ya quelque chose après la mort
peut-être ça vaut le coup d'aider les
autres messi a rien après la mort alors
je vois vraiment pas pourquoi je
prendrais soin des autres plutôt prendre
soin de moi même et s'arrêter là charité
bien ordonnée commence par soi même
les gens que j'ai rencontrés à ce moment
là m'ont dit vous voulez savoir si dieu
existe de première main parce que je
voulais plus croire sur parole vous
n'avez qu'une solution il faut méditer
alors un jour je me suis installé dans
mon salon à genoux et puis je me suis
recentré sur moi-même comme j'avais
appris à le faire dans mes formations de
psychothérapeute et j'ai le souvenir ce
qui venait puis pendant une demi heure à
peu près venue des sons comme ça et au
bout d'une demi heure j'ai eu envie de
transposer le front par terre ce que
j'ai fait et là impossible de savoir
combien de temps s'est passé cinq
minutes une demi heure j'en sais rien le
temps n'existait plus ce qui est certain
c'est que à partir de ce moment là est
depuis ce moment là pour moi il est
évident que tout absolument tout est de
l'amour
pure à conditionnelle totale ça veut
dire que l'air que nous respirons c'est
de l'amour
les sièges sur lesquels vous êtes assis
c'est de l'amour vous même chacun
d'entre vous vous êtes de l'amour pur
inconditionnels total et rien d'autre
que cela
la trame de l'univers c'est l'amour à
partir de ce moment là vous pensez bien
ma vie a changé
j'ai compris pourquoi ça me poussait à
l'intérieur accompagné encore les autres
en fait je nous ai vus comme des
étincelles d'amour au sein d'un océan
d'amour et accompagner les autres biens
c'était aider l'organisme tout entier et
j'ai aussi accompagner les gens qui le
désiraient vers ce qu'on appelle dans
les traditions d'orient l'éveil la
réalisation à cette époque là je pensais
pouvoir atteindre un bonheur durable
constant par mes propres efforts
en renouvelant des expériences mystiques
jusqu'à ce que y en a une qui deviennent
définitives et je me trompais encore il
a fallu une seconde maladie encore plus
grave que la première pour que j'en met
tous à plat que je remet tout en cause
que j'abandonne une nouvelle fois mes
idées mes pensées cru et que j'ai
découvre enfin à terme ce que je suis en
réalité à se parle de ce moment là
l'histoire de moi s'est arrêtée il ya eu
un basculement un retournement un
changement de perspective
j'ai réalisé que j'étais pas moi gérard
mais que j' étais ce que je suis qui
englobe gérard et même beaucoup plus que
cela mais je voudrais pas vous inciter à
croire tout cela sur parole plutôt je
vous propose d'aller voir de plus près
qu'est ce qu'on appelle être et si vous
le voulez bien là tout de suite on va
explorer trois façons vous savez que
vous êtes
on a pas de doute là dessus je suis on
sait on est mais qu'est ce que c'est
être la première façon là maintenant
tout de suite
sans bouger de votre siège essayé
d'arrêter d'être est ce que vous pouvez
ou non je dis pas arrêter d'exister
arrêté d'exister c'est facile on se
range la gorge on jette sous un train à
l'affairé fait non sans bouger de votre
siège essayé d'arrêter d'être et si vous
voyez vous pouvez pas qu'est ce que
c'est qu'il ne peut pas arrêter d'être
qu'est ce que c'est qui peut pas arrêter
d'être n'essayez pas de vous en saisir
n'essayez pas de le définir simplement
demeurer en tant que ce qui ne peut pas
arrêter d'être et oubliez moi un instant
et si cette façon de faire ne vous parle
pas une seconde
vous entendez le son de ma voix vous
êtes conscient du son de ma voix et vous
savez que vous êtes conscient du son de
ma voix
qu'est ce que c'est qui c'est que vous
êtes conscient du son de ma voix est là
à nouveau n'essayez pas de le définir ni
vous en saisir on ne peut pas c'est pas
mental qu'est ce que c'est et qui sait
que vous êtes conscient du son de ma
voix est demeuré simplement en tant qu'
en tant que ceux-ci qui sait que vous
êtes conscient troisième manière là
maintenant déposer tous déposé prenez un
autre mot peu importe mais de l'autre
côté
faisant abstraction oublier le ne vous
en souciez pas peu importe le verbe
déposer tous déposé les sensations et
poser les perceptions déposer les
pensées déposer les émotions déposé le
corps
l'image du corps déposés à la mémoire
négliger tout cela le monde entier
déposer tout qu'est ce qui reste
hélas bien vous dites pas ça uniquement
être ou bien on ne va rien puisqu'il n'y
a plus rien j'ai tout déposé il ya
risque plus rien est-ce que c'est qui
c'est qu'il ne reste rien il ya bien
quelque chose qui dit rien et à nouveau
demeurer en tant que ceux qui sait qu'il
ne reste rien demeurez en tant qu'être
demeurer en tant que ceux qui sait que
vous êtes conscient demeurer en tant que
ceux qui demeurent en tant que ce qui ne
peut pas ne pas être demeuré en tant que
ce qui demeure lorsque tout est déposée
demeurer en tant qu'être et simplement
laissez-vous ressentir comment s être
est ce que c'est tranquille ou agité
est ce qu'être s'en va et s'en vient ou
est-ce qu'être est toujours là que
l'organisme en ait conscience ou non
c'est curieux n'est ce pas en fait on
sait que c'est tout le temps là il y en
a quasiment jamais conscience est ce
qu'être et âgées ou jeunes ou sans âge
est ce qu'il est sexuée ou non est ce
qu'il est limité ou illimité haut ni
l'un ni l'autre
est-ce qu'il est d'humeur changeante ou
non est-ce qu'il va toujours bien
autrement dit ou pas est-ce qu'être
ressent un manque un désir est ce qu il
a des attentes
est-ce qu'il a des intentions
et être pense-t-il par lui-même ou bien
est-ce que simplement les pensées
apparaissent simplement dans le champ de
conscience de l'être
est ce qu'être effectué des choix hausse
des actes ou non comment s du point de
vue de l'être depuis cette perspective
laissez-vous le temps de répondre à ces
questions intérieurement
et puis quelle est la distance entre ce
que vous êtes et être il y en at il une
eau non et s'il n'y en a pas peut-on
dire que vous êtes être
et si vous êtes être alors vous n'êtes
pas réductible à l'organisme
et l'on peut plus loin quelle est leur
rapport entre être et l'organisme
organismes j'entends le corps le corps
mentale et tout ce qu'on croit être
d'habitude
est ce qu'être perso un auteur au sein
de l'organisme pilote au sein de
l'organisme
du point de vue de l'être est-ce que
tout arrive de soi même ou est ce qu'il
y ait un pilote qui créent les pensées
qui fait des choix qui posent des actes
demeurez en tant que ce qui ne peut pas
ne pas être content que ce qui sait que
vous êtes conscients ou en tant que ce
qui demeure lorsque tout est déposée
demeurer en tant qu'être et laissez-vous
ressentir ce que cela fait comment c'est
encore et encore et si sûr que un
premier contact avec ça comme ça être ne
se dévoile pas vraiment le plus souvent
ressent simplement ou tranquillité une
paix intérieure
mais à force d'y revenir et encore et
encore être dévoile ses qualités des
qualités sens contraire sans condition
être en réalité est amour il est joie il
est uni t il et beauté il est pur t il
et sérénité il est paix etc etc
en réalité être être exactement ce que
nous avons toujours rêvé d'être depuis
toujours
toutes les qualités que nous avons
toujours voulu acquérir développer en
nous en fait pourquoi pourquoi est ce
que nous cherchons le bonheur pourquoi
est ce que nous voulons développer la
paix l'amour en nous c'est parce que
nous le sommes et que nous l'avons
oublié c'est parce que nous ne sont plus
en contact avec ce que nous sommes en
réalité nous pensons être moi dans le
monde devant faire des choses être
efficace pertinent faire des choix posé
des actes penser correctement ne pas se
tromper c'est l'enfer ce que nous sommes
en réalité et le bonheur même est en
fait c'est ça la bonne nouvelle
vous n'avez rien à acquérir vous n'avez
rien à mériter vous n'avez rien à
chercher vous êtes déjà très exactement
tout ce que
vous cherchez merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]